Holisme
Holisme : du grec holos → tout entier, complet
La totalité est-elle plus que la somme de
ses parties?
Cette importante question est à la base du
grand clivage qui structure la sociologie.
Le holisme est l’un des deux grands courants
issus de cette rupture.
Ce courant étudie la société comme un tout
qui est plus que l’addition des comportements
individuels qui la compose.
Chaque personne est dépassée par ce tout
qui exerce sur chacun d’entre nous différentes
contraintes et nous conditionne.
Chaque membre de la société est donc soumis
à des forces sociales qui déterminent les
pratiques individuelles.
L’autre grand courant, l’individualisme
méthodologique, perçoit la société comme
la stricte agrégation des comportements individuels.
Les individus ne sont pas contraints dans
leur action.
Et l’addition de tous les comportements
individuels constitue la société.
Aujourd’hui, cette opposition est peut-être
dépassée mais c’est une histoire un peu
plus longue… qu’une shorts de la sociothèque.
A très bientôt.